so Mikey with his idea and I was like
look the ice bucket challenge such a
simple thing raise fifty million dollars
I'll be recording okay can I tell you
the challenge I wanted to do return by
the way we're talking about challenges
and raising awareness I drink only
really good whiskey dude add only in
travel mugs oh this is so much it's
really is sweet I want to do you know
like I get obsessed with promotion for
Instagram I wanted to do the ice carrot
challenge where you sit and it shot from
here from here up I go hey it's Bert
Kreischer I'm gonna put an ice carrot up
my [ __ ] right now and then but I you
don't do it but you see the look on the
person's eyes ago all right here we go
and it's who can make it believable the
most like okay I'm doing this friend of
mine said he's been in a long-term
relationship he goes I just having sex
with my girl is just not doing it for me
anymore so I got to think a sick [ __ ]
now just get it going I go yeah and he
goes I know man I'm like I gotta sit
there I'm thinking about getting [ __ ]
in the ass keep your dong hard I was
like that I gotta say about getting
[ __ ] in these that's actually not what
would get my pony your you know [ __ ]
yeah oh my god there's what I got whisky
wise I got these tribal well you know
I'm an airplane that's regular whiskey
I'm not true I will definitely okay okay
I'm not gonna twist your arm of
everything drink I have an 18 year old
that's get home you I did not know
you're gonna say whiskey
I got an 18 year old oh wait oh yeah
who's your other out come on would you
rather have an 18 year old dancer you
can do both though [ __ ] dancers if
I'm never going to come [ __ ] married
but would love to [ __ ] a dancer like
what kind of dance are like a JLo oh
yeah I want someone but ethnic am i
right guys yes all right I want someone
who can read my timing so when she does
this I don't like time in with her that
were both
at the same time that's what my mother
night - yeah I need someone to read my
energy to lead me yeah black go mm-hmm
did you say you need a white girl who
it's rare though you know it's hip-hop
are you know [ __ ] broke a figure it out
- I wouldn't mind don't work yeah my
wife's getting laser treatment on the
face and it's working as it be she looks
so lucky your wife is a beautiful
attractive young man guys girls do have
like a little bit of mustaches oh dude I
dated a girl I won't say her name cuz
she works at Disney now she gotta end
this story right now how do they not
notice how they not wake up Mike oh [ __ ]
I need to initiate whiskers what's the
equivalent of that for men you know
brows are like long nose hairs right Oh
like long nose hairs are a problem you
but how do you not know that no more if
you have just [ __ ] breath a really bad T
terrible they come on I have a black
tooth right here that guy's just changed
colors and I got a let's test yeah no
that's thing about going gold yeah you
look sick with just a solid right in a
weird spot yeah they'll never be another
girl had hair on her nipples yo yep
Hortis the girl oh yeah I used to have a
girl that when we do reverse cowgirl she
had one long hair out of her [ __ ] did
you like a lot they're not bike no let's
not do this [ __ ] one I had a girl I
just have a girl the worst law a girl
who had the biggest dick balls - dude
I'm dug in too long like strong black
hair but well we can't do that I can
never understand guys that are into
trans trans trans gender I think
transgenders are now they're girls
transsexual is the ones that like party
with both yeah
know that there are people that have
tits and also a dick there's no doubt
and they keep it yeah yeah but so they
look really female but sometimes like I
have a dick dude sometimes my again you
porn bite you may we suggest this and
I'm like damn that's a hot ass chick
yeah a fat dick that's right but it's a
very attractive girls right that's right
I've seen some [ __ ] up [ __ ] on you
porn yeah I saw this thing first of all
what's your favorite thing to watch on
there though
backdoor casting couch that's pretty fun
backdoor cast again and I pretend his
Jon Favreau cuz he sounds like Jon
Favreau and and dude I could recognize
that guy in a [ __ ] locker room yeah
with his hernia scar and his [ __ ] he
sometimes does steroids sometimes
doesn't your fabric van yeah I'm big
Favreau fan no I'm talking about the guy
yeah a little dick right the little dick
not the biggest dick yeah I watch it for
the look on their face uh-huh
like I actually found backdoor casting
couch outtakes where the girls say no
and they're [ __ ] awesome
obviously it's basically a me-too video
right the biggest hashtag me Harvey
Weinstein like me to skipped over the
porn industry quickest [ __ ] well they
just assume everybody watches it oh do
your present do your present Brian of
the woke girl at the porn conference
talking about me too and then getting
shut down in that mouth I like the I
like your tits that's that's deep here
of our girl micro acting class was never
very good and she was really hot and my
friend she gets to be sincere scenes and
it would always be a disaster my friend
my friend these people are ham has heard
men turn around this one girl just
awesome I like this wow yeah
totally there's something really primal
about that we were in somewhere in
Louisiana doing that old-school Mardi
Gras Festival where you had to go catch
the chickens and you make the gumbo
together and then you guys walk through
with like horseback and you walk through
the town and Eunice and Eunice Louisiana
and our producer was a feminist and she
was trying to get these guys to champ
for Travel Channel and one of the guys
just and it's like the perfect bro
moment he goes right Hey and she looks
over excuse giannios show them tits out
for the boys talk show in New York City
immature boys back in the middle school
I know in New York did with these two
are the two women who were like
professionals and they would they would
talk about spiritual stuff and they're
talked about it was all positive energy
and the mistake they made is they had a
live call and that one time I laughed
the hardest was they're talking and
they're like yeah right and that's right
and that's a very good point and I'm
sorry to interrupt you but that's such a
good point and I think that's that's
something that we all need to keep in
mind that we have to come together let's
take a call and he hit the guy he's here
a guy I think he goes he goes well why
did you just go to the guy gets on
another time with insane things she goes
hello you're on there anything is I want
to suck your tits she's so immature
did you see I think was I'm good more in
America you know they're always live in
New York
yeah like interviewed sorry
some guy just comes like a broken Faisal
sucker [ __ ] just the first or the first
the first girl to write the [ __ ] at me
on the floor [ __ ] right the [ __ ] and
I was like [ __ ] right the [ __ ] high and
you see the bro just like anything
outrageous that takes to check the
chessboard and throws it in the air Oh
John I do it to my daughter all the time
[Music]
guys just a creep hey it's not cool by
the way man it's not cool when it's you
as the TV host because I that happened
to me on Travel Channel all the [ __ ] you
[ __ ] dude you'd be up there doing an
interview and just kids would run in we
were in theme parks kids you just run up
[ __ ] her right in the [ __ ] I was like
dude I was in the middle of being almost
done work it's funny I know it's funny
for kid when kids do it
you know what's weird to me is whenever
there's like when NFL gamer broadcasts
and they're showing the people in the
back or like first take and the fans and
he seemed like walked by and they're all
like this or on the phone and we can do
with that die now who are you calling
see me in this hour I did that in Dallas
I was walking is they had this I think
is Dallas they had this TV show at the
bottom where the Mavericks played and I
was walking by we're going to do press
and we're walking by and they're on
there and I was like walk in I'm doing
that [ __ ] proud I had this weird urge
that guy got me good to kidding that guy
who got me good
oh [ __ ] I keep talking I forget what he
said something to me on air in the
middle of a story that just shot my
story down my first interview I didn't
know I was being taken I'd call it on a
radio show and they go Brian colon is aw
[ __ ] no but yeah yeah yeah I think so
Brian tell us about what it's like to
work with Roseanne
I was like I don't that that's a
different sketch I do magic Ryan :
so tell us ago was Callens yes and they
I got mad cuz I didn't get the joke I
thought the guy was just an idiot yeah
hey it's Callen you jackass he goes okay
Bryan : thank you so much falling dude
how about when I was doing watch what
happens live with Andy Cohen they took
calls and they don't know like the MMA
fan bases retake yes the real-life
caller here and the guys like yeah hi
you know millions of people watch that
[ __ ] show Danny Cohen okay yeah this
is Dave from Milwaukee
I heard you suck Joe Rogan off of the
Comedy Store one time and then andy zall
he doesn't know he's all did you yeah
how's all oh that's not that's not real
look at Andy I think he's talking to you
yeah Adam I think you got me and Andy
confused yes I get my daughter my
daughters I get them all the time
there's no better feeling at the hotel
they get in the pool and just go out to
the balcony
Georgia ila mom says the pools gonna
bother your butt rash medicine and just
shut down I did it I did it to my
daughter's friend
my daughter's friend where the George's
birthday parties the other night and I
didn't Instagram stories I was like her
mom goes Kylie's got diarrhea no I'm not
but I go man nothing like having diary
at a birthday party and I swing to her
and she goes no oh every night tagged
her she was like I want more fans I want
to be an influencer on Instagram I was
like there you go there you go I found
it funny did you see some [ __ ] [ __ ]
him find it some [ __ ] award show
some gal or something and this lady just
you know she just bright I have a lot of
experience you know what she's doing and
she's interviewing this this other girl
and she goes so uh who are you wearing
tonight and she goes Kate Spade she goes
I love her did you come with her tonight
and the girls like well yeah I came with
her she's like you where's she at
where she cuz I had a lot fall where is
she at and they're girls like you can
tell they're girls like what I came with
her team she's like well when she comes
by but definitely told her stop on by
and then she's like back to you J name
and then it result more thing yeah
here she is is this her the c-d-c BFF
whatever dude it took me I don't know 17
years to realize that she's married to
David Spade's brother did you know yeah
I knew that yes that Kate Spade was
nothing because it lasts in spades David
Spade's brother ah yes yes yeah sister
sister Kate Spade is David Spade's
sister oh really
no no no his brother made married to
David Spade's brother that's why since
she committed suicide yeah yeah that
hurts why the joke word well is that
Hannah gas beat media-based the
ambrose's question and for Bronfman see
it another one of my favorite American
design what made you pick a are you here
with Kate here at Kate see here well and
before her or did she skip by me well
Kate the team from Kate is know she
didn't know the kid Spade could commit
suicide I want but a long time ago rash
roof yeah oh yeah oh it's been out oof
yeah that's a time those are so funny to
me men cuz actually didn't mean to she
issued an apology kind of it yeah
there's something that is beautiful
about the internet and like kind of what
we do is not knowing you don't need to
know everything on a podcast you don't
need to have all the answers a lot of
bro sites oh dude we when I was on TV I
was on FX me and Gary Valentine
interviewed iceberg slim and I said what
are we gonna say to him
go ahead Gary why don't you say like Sid
you'd like I'll go like do you really
hit women you know and and he was and
and then you go show me how hard you hit
a woman on my hand right yeah just show
on FX
this is Oda back I don't know I first
time I'm sorry so I go so we start the
interview we're talking about his book
pimping or whatever we're like psycho so
iceberg do you really hit hit a woman
like it he goes yeah [ __ ] acting on
line up got a smack a [ __ ] and Gary
goes no hard he goes well as hard as you
got to hit him you gotta hit him and
it was okay say I'm a [ __ ] and I'm
acting up like show me on my hand and he
smacked Gary's hand hardest [ __ ] and
studio audits everyone silent you can
hear he just put his hands down he's
like what's up we got real sad dude that
was ice berg ain't no [ __ ] hi so there
is that ma'am
oh do you miss her cuz you got I mean
you do a lot of [ __ ] we do you miss TV
at all no and I miss I never got to do
script it really I'd like to try it
acting uh yeah I meant it acting I just
wasn't I was uh I was like you hear a
good story I did a sitcom probably like
1999
maybe with Elliott Gould oh my god yeah
yeah Gold Hall of Fame actor so Elliot
Gould past your time bring him up Jim
cuz I mean wait and these guys Elliott
Gould we're all that a table read he's
fantastic we're all of you that he's are
making history X comma kite yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah never stopped working
that's right
we uh we're at a table read now you get
obsessed I find out that Elliott Gould
was married to Barbra Streisand
so my go Elliott like before I'll sit
where everyone's like there's exactly
one is around I go Elliott Elliott all
right got about to the table ready go
you married to Barbra Streisand and he
goes yeah yeah I was I go Barbra
Streisand you married Barbra Streisand
is I guess yes I did and they go wow I
go what's she like he goes a [ __ ] can we
start this table read yeah he's probably
didn't want to do it can we start this
table reso then so then what Elliott
Gould Mian Elliott Gould
we we gotta do you know more about
sitcoms I do but it's like pickups at
the we did the pilot right yeah but
wasn't perfect so we got to do pickups
like which are alternate lines for
everything so one of the lines that
wasn't working as are the woman that
woman walked in Elizabeth god damnit I
wish I knew her name she we probably
know her um she walked in she was the
bride-to-be and she would come in and go
mm-hmm hey you guys are drinking beers
before the wedding
can I have a beer and then my role is
the best friend was like of course but
they wanted it so that like that of
course really showed that we had a
friendship right right so we do it like
19 different ways oh sure thing exists
of
course all these reads that the
network's giving me so la goons playing
a blind man he's standing behind me with
a dog and he's playing a blind guy
looking off the side they walk away it's
like 2:00 in the morning and he leans
down he goes
improv won and they go yeah and he goes
yeah trust me improv one it'll be the
one they use so she comes in she goes
hey can I get a beer and I go is a
duck's ass watertight get in here and it
gets a huge laugh right gray showrunner
comes up to me smiling gets right up to
me
I'll eat cools right behind me he goes
you are [ __ ] me in the [ __ ] ass
right now I got bent over and [ __ ] in
the ass by you in front of all the
friends acts and he walks away Elliott
Gould still playing a guy and got blind
guy and just goes sorry
married to Mindy Schultz ice and did you
have to guess you don't hear it no you
don't remember the name of the sitcom no
life with David J life we can get picked
up right now to get picked automatic but
did you uh mean to me and Elliot Gould
were cooled out like he ended up giving
me his number and we can't we talked all
the time [ __ ] numbers Maxim right I
ran into him I ran into him in front of
sag
those are my wife and my family and he
goes Bert I turn around and my
father-in-law's like you know Elliott
Gould is he still alive
yeah oh yeah he was a really interesting
guy still working something now did you
at the audition for that right yeah
did you do acting classes anything you
know is rolling oh did acting class but
it confused me it caught me like all my
head and then I just I went in I had to
deal at CBS at the time so I went in I
did the read oh he had a notions a Fox
and Fox loved me I mean I killed it that
one that one read I did with them I
murdered is the only time I ever did
that right ever do you want to be an
actor I don't know oh yeah a little bit
yeah I wouldn't mind having a job on I
wouldn't mind doing a form of multicam
for camera sitcom on CBS Radford I would
love that I would love that live song so
close yeah I would say you think you
would take time off the road and be
happy about it yeah I think so
really I think I think I enjoy
storytelling so if I was a part of the
process of writing the story like today
we had a comment with a conference call
about about a sitcom that we're gonna do
or whatever and they were asking stuff
about my daughters and how my daughter's
deal with social media and I had said
something on Rogen yesterday
which is true my daughter's hate when
I'm on social media so when I pull up my
phone is stories they do stuff and they
go mom dad hits mom in the background
and I go hey dad says the N word and I'm
like save if I can't post them and they
told it to them I love that I would love
to incorporate that I'd love to be in a
storytelling concept but like a Larry
David it's your life yeah that's a great
idea like a Larry David David you're a
loveable Larry do we see cabe yeah Maron
vibe and such you're way more fun than
all those guys that's the thing about
you you're very honest and vulnerable
and likable yeah like Bert the only
reason I got sighs are some people the
only reason I got this sitcom so I
killed it Fox I go over to CBS to do the
do the test at CBS and les Moonves walks
in and I had a yes and let's move as
sits down and the whole rooms there
other I've been that room yeah many
times he goes uh Oh Bert no I go I look
at him and I go it's up les and he was
Bert good to see you again I go we've
never met and the room does what the
[ __ ] and he goes we haven't and I said I
definitely would remember that hair and
he laughs and he goes yeah and I said
how did you end up on that side of the
camera what looks like that and an actor
he was an actor and he goes ho ho I'm
gonna like this read did the read my
bombed he gave it to me in that room yes
yeah maybe 13 maybe 20 times how many
times did he go right once yeah once
because you give that room would be heat
stayed walk-in he's really cool though
yeah like he you know say we welcome
girls yeah there's always issues but he
was the Godfather and the most
successful man in TV you know easy and
he'd go in there man it was emperor's
new clothes nobody would laughing until
he laughed it was it was such a tight
room
it was that that [ __ ] weird room we
delet still it was it row me off every
time I hated that room like that caught
us in here that power uh you know yeah
yeah there's still those big big weights
like you know the bit the bigwig at a
network see everybody's terrified right
and the reason they're terrified is
because when you're a network executive
your mortgage your kids private school
everything is riding on the seasons
being successful now I get it when it's
not successful your orbital overlords go
something's got to change and you get
fired or move but if you is you are
successful so that's why when they when
they are looking at actors nobody wants
to be the guy who chooses the actor that
sucked or the actor that that made a
tank there everybody said when the head
honcho goes that's the guy everybody
goes oh that is the gift that's the guy
you know let's move our jobs are safe
yeah I know he found James Corden he
found Jane he was at a play in England
and you know James Corden was on
Broadway basically and he was at a play
and he was watching him do his thing and
he's like oh [ __ ] they get they get
should host tonight's show you're such a
talent and went up to massive players
like remember less has seen so many
people come and go I see is good as it
gets
I really don't get tight in those
situations I think I just don't care
yeah I haven't been something that big
for me are those big situations I don't
because I have other things going on
it's like oh this doesn't work out I'm
good me see for me for me it was it was
either get this and I could buy a house
or I literally have about now you're not
that no it's different that's why it
we're all word in one eye back then
there was the gods made the decision I
hear you you there was only only one
place and you didn't get it and it was
like there was a pilot season there's a
really small wheel to get any job you
could then you went the rest of the year
without a job you know what I got a job
you got to think about this we're also
talking about what I mean I must have it
back then you were talking about 25
episode 20 that was a guarantee
25 50 grand an episode you Silent Hill
before it's you know comic was making 25
grand on the road no one whoa yeah now
it's like five grand one's making 25
grand on the on the road it seems like
and but dude I remember that I remember
going into auditions
this is brings back weird feelings going
um I got a pay rent like desperate how
about that desperate I I've been in
rooms where I was desperate where I
where I was just like I just was I was
like I can't do this anymore I can't you
know the only time I get tense is like
last night was doing stores that I'm
shows at the Comedy Store
I knew Adam was watching I get tense
Adam the Pharisees I still get tense at
the store every now and then just
because it I mean I get tense sometimes
do a stand-up but man I haven't thought
about this in forever but like I
remember I remember going in like
nervous about shows I didn't [ __ ]
want but I didn't want to do but I knew
I needed the money I took a job on a
show that was produced by one of the
Impractical Jokers Murr it was called a
let's bowl or something like that or
something bold sounds off and it was
like a celebrity poker tournament
remember those but with bowling and I
was the host it was so bad sad and it
was like I knew thirteen grand 10 grand
but didn't burn and wrote you've told a
story before many times but didn't Burr
and Rogan sit you down the comic store
like what the [ __ ] you doing on TV yeah
yeah Joe did it to me twice
but yeah but uh burn Rogan one time
can't I walked in and there and I was
like I said something about how long
goes this first of all is four years ago
three years ago I said something about
some it's something celebrity you know
how like that you've got a rub Joe wrong
sometimes and or ember it rubs them low
if you talk about celebrity and they
just were like dude your TV show sucks
and I was like well I love you we love
you you're much better stand up than you
are host don't be like you're not a
celebrity guy you're not a famous guy
your comic don't ever forget that you're
a comic and they're like best
happen to you is you quit that show and
you get back in the comedy you got to do
a special and Joe got into it he was
like you need you need to do a special
you need to be doing spots at the store
all the time you need to be on the road
you're neglecting your stand-up help
you're neglecting your podcast there's
money you're leaving money on the table
for your podcast and on the road and
where were you at during this time when
he told you this I just I just decided
to do Burt the Conqueror again and so I
was like that's the show on and I know
how to deal a Travel Channel had like a
four year deal that was coming up kind
of money we talking about
no I eight hundred thousand a year
that's a lot yeah a year that's a lot of
money say not a lot I'm sorry you don't
know what with my but I was in a deal I
was an overall deal so the way I do my
deal works and I apologize to anyone he
still let's I would assume here making
ha the episodes though you were doing
yeah I was signed up for doing 13
episodes per year to shitload of money
Avellino but here's the deal GOP I had I
had so let's hypothetically say
hypothetical numbers gotta remember the
exact numbers let's say it was $10,000
in episode the breakdown for the overall
deal so overall deal was worth say for
that year $400,000 right for one year
they break that up into 13 episodes or
20 episodes whatever they felt they were
gonna shoot and then if you shot more
episodes than that they got put into
penalty and then all of a sudden your
money got like time-and-a-half timeless
so all of a sudden your money doubled
with an extra more and I did everything
for them they said go to [ __ ] Hawaii
and pick up and dig taro plants I dug
taro plants cuz I knew I'd do three
episodes over there and that was gonna
be time to have your money at this point
Dober know but I had never been I never
had money just coming in there's a lot
of [ __ ] money a lot of nobody's
making back in the day that was a there
was like three years ago those four
pilot I was probably three years ago my
last year doing Travel Channel I made
the most money I ever made because I did
like two series but three series I would
just do a series I would do everything I
would do everything they asked and I
loved it I mean I was I was so and
you're traveling the world you wanted
yeah I bet your daughters didn't like it
oh dude I was gone oh at my schedule was
two weeks out when we come two weeks out
won't we cause it's awful for there's
all
horrific it's the biggest regret I have
is I missed a lot because I was working
I was working I was you did this before
years I did this for nine years
I didn't know that burns yeah I did it
for nine years I was on Travel Channel
where you travel to everything
everywhere in the world whatever but you
must like just put you in the show doing
it for nine years
I loved the crew I love being with the
crew I loved looking up skinny eyes but
that didn't hold on beat that didn't
sell tickets for you many tickets to
do-nothings and by the way I'm doing
Rogen like people come out and go I
didn't know you did stand-up I thought
you're just one of his Travel Channel
friends and you were like oh no I've
been a stand-up my whole life I get
fired from Travel Channel but it's like
to get fired
they just didn't like me there's new
management you for nine years a new man
a new president came in that's what
happens they get a fresh they want a
fresh your friends don't want their guy
yeah so you got fired
yeah your bump I'll do so bummed you
have no idea
I was I was an old guy this poor woman
Courtney White's her name had to listen
to me grovel on the phone I'm so
embarrassed what does she do how I she
was a new president all right he's like
listen we're going a new direction we're
gonna part ways with you we're not
running in contract best of luck in your
future you know you got a lot of fans
over here technically she was saying I'm
not one of them but and then I literally
was like okay well you know I've always
chosen I'm pitching and just you know
I'm really I'm only I don't really go to
stay with you guys I don't wanna go to
another network so like if you guys dude
I am so embarrassed about her and she
just was like like she was breaking up
me she's like okay okay okay okay I got
it I got everything yeah click we're
here anything hung up on me I go home my
wife goes good news they can see you
they can you can get your vasectomy now
they have an opening today and I was
like uh-huh
they're demoing my house I got a call
from Live Nation I'm supposed to do the
Funny or Die tour and they canceled all
12 of the daytime on why my Showtime
special airs no one [ __ ] watches it
no one wanted Showtime
yeah Eddie shut the Machine story was on
Showtime and the grime on and I'm I'm
like I get into therapy I'm like I'm
like I'm [ __ ] lost man I have morning
I have a conversation with Tom we talked
about the money we're making at
different clubs and
that time though give us frames
murdering it he's about to buy a house
he's done his first theater tour and
sold out everything added shows he's my
best friend
no jealousy two friends talking about
money and Tom going don't worry men
we'll get your money your podcast
monetized we'll get you out of this hole
you're gonna eat I'm telling you keep
working keep doing specials keep selling
tickets and I was in Celsius I was in
st. Louis right before you were this is
I love helium I'm doing Indiana this
weekend helium shameless I said tomorrow
mark I'm not going to st. Louis I just
can't do I don't like the town the town
doesn't do it whoo I like the town I
don't like the club back to your story
um so you're in st. Louis after Brian
sold seven tickets I do yep I do New
Year's Eve I get you ready for this time
we're really talking money I'm sure
someone's gonna be [ __ ] I love it 25
grand guaranteed for New Year's Eve in
Oxnard right I move maybe a hundred and
fifty tickets for the whole week that
levity
levity they just opened it Tom had been
there two weeks before working on new
material sold out the weekend and I'm
thinking how do and I'm just like being
honest like specials I know how does how
did they not know about me we're best
friends like how do they not know about
me Tom's fat shaming me at the time
right he's fat shaming me I'm trying to
lose weight we're gonna do the weigh-ins
on Rogen's podcast I hire a marketing
team to try to get people to watch my
special on Netflix they guarantee me
millions of downloads they don't deliver
on any of that none of my clips go viral
none of that the day before New Year's
Eve I just go [ __ ] it I post the Machine
story cuz I just forgot post the Machine
story on Facebook did you own it was it
from Showtime by the way once again I
really feel this is like the ruin your
career podcast notes I misread my
contract is show time I misread the
contract it said four clips and they met
four clips of under 30 seconds yes I'm
hosted 37 minutes of my special
oh and what happened and so and I post
the Machine story mmm goes viral like
I'd never seen so I never had anything
like that in my life when I ate goes the
first night it gets like I'm like
looking at it and I'm looking it's like
20,000 views but it's got 15,000 shares
I go that seems like a lopsided number
and then all of a sudden it's like that
next morning 3 million then then that
night 7 million and then 9 million and
15 mm and then what happened is other
people started ripping it and posting it
on their page and you'd watch that like
this one dude I forget his name my
manager knows it 80 million views on his
page like and you're just like whoa and
it just starts screaming up the top I go
to marketing can't pay for it by the way
nothing but marketing company calls me
and says so why don't you pick that day
I go excuse me and they're like that day
that's a really interesting day that you
chose to post that because the way that
it was set up Christmas and New Year's
kind of side saddled a weekend to battle
time almost had like two weeks off
almost the way that that were that one
year worked and so the day I posted it
on the 27th of January or December it
was like they were opening Christmas
presents but they had a whole week off
it was like it was like a weird time to
post it dude I go to the first weekend I
go to New Jersey stress factory and
there's a blizzard and Vinny brands like
dude you sawed off the [ __ ] weekend
you sawed off the [ __ ] weekend I go
to the next weekend in Buffalo same
blizzard Marc Grossman is like you sold
off the [ __ ] weekend and all sudden I
start looking like oh well I'm selling
out I was like ah change all my [ __ ]
deals I was like I'm not no guarantees I
want a percentage and then from that
that one video changed my life and then
from land you just were like I mistake
stand-up and then I was like I was like
[ __ ] TV like they called me up like hey
we got this on no TV yeah stand up I was
like in my head I said and this sounds
good sound cocky but like I always knew
I was a good stand-up but I was like I I
believe if I focus only on stand-up for
this entire year and I had figured 18
months I could shoot a slam and special
because I had so much material backlog
that I had never really liked I've got
to do and I I remember working that next
our out immediately the second that our
dropped I dropped everything and started
brand new and fresh I did have a lot of
materials I had another special in a
while kept telling machine story at the
end I do an hours in the material
telling me she in a story and everyone's
super happy but um and and then and then
once I got the green light from Netflix
to do a special dude I became obsessive
compulsive that work ethic and travel
channel where two weeks out when we come
I was like I turned that into stand-up
and I would do Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday at clubs
do one-nighters two shows one-nighters
two shows one night around weekend on
the road I did that hour probably 150
times just obsessive and I dude and I
took that hour I got I got crazy about
it I was like I'd hear stuff like I
remember daliyah one time in the in the
in the green rooms like dude they only
watched 30 minutes of specials on
Netflix and I was like what he's like
the only watched 30 minutes and specials
and I hit up Netflix I was like hey they
only watched 30 minutes and they're like
yeah people turn it off after 30 minutes
so I was like [ __ ] that my closer goes
at 25 minutes so if you watch that
special I took everything that I like
rated it one one to thirty about all the
bits I had everything that was [ __ ]
the best went in that first 25 minutes
and then I was like and then I'll tell
my and then I'll keep going just I want
people to stick around see I think a and
you know this bird I think Birds one of
the greatest comedians alive but one of
the best things that bird does is
marketing he's so [ __ ] good at it yeah
social media everything's so good I like
hold the whole touring bus and all
everything but yeah but is social media
the promos everything so good yeah the
other comics that don't sell takers I'm
like dude look look at look at the other
guys doing it man do I think we don't
want like New York you to your comments
who trash me but in like but like just
make fun of the idea like Ari hates oh
okay no like me like we're all friends
and stuff but like every comics like oh
so what are we gonna do another promo
video like I am cuz I sell out my next
show yeah and also we want to go on
stage we can do this I never
had the like I never had the like stamp
of like um of like tastemakers I'm like
yeah yeah I've never had that and never
bloody variety top ten comics to watch
or or I never got put into anything I
never went to a festival ever in my
career no one's ever like but you should
do Montreal the Montreal never wanted me
I had to find a finagle my way into 92
but when you're a tastemaker and there's
a list of comics that we could name
right now there are people that just
were I'm not saying gifted as a real
factor there's a really strange cool
factor that's always been there I've
noticed for 25 years I mean it happened
in New York when I first started yeah
there were just the cool kids that would
get there they get plucked at New York
Times The New York Times and and various
like back then like the people that are
influencing the culture shows what I'd
be like why I I mean I I think I miss I
think I become like that that'd be yeah
talk to me about
we were working I never got that like
louis c.k was always cool he would he's
underground cool took forever but a lot
of guys a lot of guys were but but a lot
of guys were the darlings of of the
media back then
yeah like that of course
yeah base makers where there are a lot
of really good guys and sometimes the
tastemakers like the New York Times they
have as they like they just it is what
it is it's just it's there there you're
dealing with probably a handful of
people that make it different let me ask
you this maybe why do you think you were
never one of those guys because everyone
I thought I'm not just saying this
because brands were my best friends but
everyone I talked to is like but even
before I was in stands like Brian's one
the most talented stand-ups on though
he's been forever yeah and I keep it
even Bill Simmons on his podcast in one
of his shows they watch old movies they
watch The Hangover and use your little
clip and they go Brian if he was given
ten lifetimes nine out of ten he's a
absolute superstar sluggishness I'll
jump in right now and by the way I can
say this I love Zack I love Zack Zack
Zack Arrakis and in Zack can feel can
obviously feel free to disagree i'm
bannin this is not slandering Zack but
man Zack was a darling of the end
yes like a darling meaning like he got
he got a TV show it would fail no no no
give another one you got and by the way
I'm not [ __ ] chances I mean he's got
a lot of chances and he always got like
if there was a cool comedy show to go to
Zac was always booked on it like I mean
like I remember going to things and and
Zac was booked on everything by the way
Zac is amazingly funny I cannot discount
it he's so talented and ways that people
don't know talent but but there there
are people that were equivalent to Zac
to got those opportunities that were not
as talented they just dressed his way or
they acted his way or they were snooty
or they condescending so that's what I
thought I was gonna say there's a
certain cool factor I think part of the
Zac was cool I was really a solid is I
was obvious I was I would go in there
prepared and I make you laugh hard night
and I was a little vain don't you think
you but you I think your thing be for
long stand-up is you want to be an actor
so bad you need liked it stand up I did
but I'd always done it I know you're a
monster
no I guess so III think it was all more
the fact that there's something really
cool about a comic that makes you reach
a comic that's not always trying to be
the funniest but rather trying to be but
you were very irreverent like yours very
you want to be a movie star to be funny
you want to be a movie star
yes and when you have somebody who's a
satirist like if you have a Dave
Chappelle who's like who's not even
worried about making you laugh he's more
worried about saying something while
he's smoking there's something very cool
and chic about that stuff louis c.k
there was near reverence with a lot of
these guys for me I just wanted you to
like me and I was up there Dean Dean is
a perfect example yes and this is deny
that but like dude I could watch Janine
bomb forever I am fascinated by like she
the way Garofalo the way her brain works
I can she makes me that she was one of
the cool and she was she was one of the
cool like and then I think guys like me
and Brian who were like you know like
rip your shirt off [ __ ] it like Sarah
Silverman there was there by the way
we're all very Italian it means amazing
Soyoung armour 0 so young she was
Silverman I've no against Arab for 25
years I like I was saying something like
it's Adele yeah I think she's [ __ ]
hot that she's a member of Mayor Sam
cedar members as Sam said do you mind
yeah these were brilliant but says Sarah
was Sarah was killer and as Sarah is
[ __ ] electioned legend monster yeah
Garry Shandling you know [ __ ] protégé
what we talked about but she was always
this she was always the girls I remember
I'm Erin still funny when you think back
I was so young and they said well Sarah
was hair was that just got back from LA
and I was in New York were like oh yeah
what's she doing was she did you know
what it was you know it's Sarah there's
there's something that of that oh and by
the way I will say this about everyone
we just talked about and that group of
cool kids that we always say like they
always got put in a variety top-10 and
this and that there was something about
them like a weird kind of confidence
where they didn't give a [ __ ] and like I
said Brian line maybe never had that I
never had that confidence I was like
have it now though right because when
there's a we have a glue now I know
there's like things cool there's like a
boys club right it's like lose your
reference cuz you go oh hold on first of
all I was so impressed with people in
suits I just thought they knew much more
than I did so I would go in there and I
just wanted to please them like when I
did let him and they said you got to
wear a suit I went and bought a really
excited $900 to I didn't have a net even
have the money
and I went and bought that and I was
like I'll be a good boy what else do I'm
gonna do dude I was so nervous you hear
stories about guys who [ __ ] the system
my caps dude Mike Epps went in for a
read at the UPN right and he goes he
does the read they're like yeah that's
great you know I really can't understand
you can you do it I still keep it black
but like these are all white people
he'll keep a flat but do it less blood
is the story Mike Epps told me by the
way I swear to God I could not compile
less open then he goes so he does it
again right no no no we like it can you
make it more like a like a like a New
York hip-hop like a New York hip-hop and
my caps looks at them at the table
reading goes yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ]
how you like that and got up and walked
out
yeah dude I never had that confidence
Brian and I were always I want to get
the job yeah then I wanted to be liked
there's something uncool about a guy who
really wants to be liked and who doesn't
have the confidence didn't smell the
desperation it's like a girl I wasn't
even tell you I can't I was just up but
even a dude he's super thirsty
it turns the girls on that's where that
was my whole career in a lot of ways I
was just I just wanted it liked and I
didn't have the confidence in myself and
I didn't even think I belong there
it was so in like I knew beasts right so
interesting to him you hear you tell it
like that Brooks I don't since I've
known Edith gotten to come and you've
been this monster no but I was I was the
guy that like if I felt like there were
rules in line I wanted to follow the
rules I want to be the guy that took too
many chances
it wasn't till I started taking my shirt
off and I want to show time I was like
hey I'm doing on my shirt off I remember
Tom laughs so [ __ ] hard he was like
why would you do that and I was like
that's how I do stand-up that's you and
it's I get embarrassed of it sometimes
at the store I won't take my shirt off
because I don't want to like I don't
want to like ruffle feathers someone
going bro it's obviously you take your
shirt off it's gonna be easier for you
to kill but I go but that's how I like
to ask who would do that
a lot of people may be shocked how many
people pull the insides but please don't
take your shirt off tonight yeah and so
he knows who he is and he's very
grateful that I'm not saying his name
but you tell miss off there because when
I was on the same show as you in the
culture in the back saying how bad you
crush like after I've heard it like you
know like last night at the fall
Sebastian and before that to follow
[ __ ] Bobby Lee and you know monsters
and I've never heard this group I'm
gonna say the names group of comics just
Bert was on the line I'm like you tell
they're all around like but that nobody
wants to follow birth not especially
I mean in general they start off right
now ringing all I gotta do is go a
marathon it's like no you got this bit
right now yeah I know you talking about
give it away and you they were like
trying to figure it out
I've never seen it before my favorite
bit I've ever written in my entire
[ __ ] life I'm talking let the main
room on fire Brian I'm so glad to hear
you talk like this because that was
defined me like that I find the concept
of wanting to
in and wanting to like not ruffle
feathers and do what they said and like
like oh yeah like my first special
cowhide you know my counselor cow head
he's a big DJ in Tampa I did my special
I went I had the meeting and the for
Comedy Central comfortably dumb and they
go um so just you know like what works
well best on cameras like a dark shirt
dark jeans but it's not like with like
the kind that have like lighten it like
I just do die I followed suit I did a
special this is 2009 you gotta look it
up I did a special me bill burr um Chris
Titus and Pete Cory Ali were the exact
same outfit pull up any of us in the
2009 Comedy Central specials we all were
the same [ __ ] outfit you know and Cal
had said to me guys so what do you think
my special he goes I don't know it looks
like you were dressed to be a comedian
that like in uniform yeah I go what do
you mean universe some of its the way
you're raised like I was raised and to
believe that there's a power structure
and and that you do what you're told
oh well you're a great [ __ ] for you
pee so bad only hear the story so bad
might be might hold it hold the story
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you ready yeah so right before I get Jam
right before I get fired from Travel
Channel I'm in my parents have a beach
house in Clearwater so we're down to the
beach house and light a cigar have a
glass of wine my wife's there my mom's
there it's me and my dad and he says so
what's going on you're gonna do that uh
Showtime special I said well first and
foremost I want to get reassigned by
travel to us my biggest thing
my dad's phrase to me in life was eat
[ __ ] cash cheques Yeah right
I was his phrase god [ __ ] cast Jack's
right awful he passed us unsafe on the
yep didn't want to be a lawyer in life
I'll be a lawyer
eat [ __ ] cash checks had dreams put your
dreams off the side eat [ __ ] cash
Chester my wife school wants to be a
singer honey honey honey raise kids he
[ __ ] cash checks will that make this so
I say to my dad
what so I say to my dad yeah I just want
to hopefully I'll get reassigned by
travel to and then I won't have to worry
about anything for a few years and by
then I'll be 50 or you know 45 and
you know I don't know we'll figure it
out and I said to my dad I mean thinking
nothing would happen I go you know
eat [ __ ] cast jacks I'm gonna be like 42
at the time 43 my dad starts crying mmm
aggressively crying goes he goes oh oh
my god
oh I [ __ ] you up I [ __ ] you up news
I was like what I'm gonna get emotional
he's like I [ __ ] you up no he's
sitting cash checks is for me like it's
not for you you have talent I had
nothing Oh God and he says buddy oh he
goes if you don't roll the dice on
yourself now you're gonna look back and
regret life and I went really and he
goes if your of your buddy's had told
about burn rogen because if your buddies
are telling you to get away from Travel
Channel get away from Travel Channel and
I was like really and he was like and in
my head I was like oh we'll see what
happens if they Simon who do you know
but man when I got fired it was the
greatest thing and I kept thinking my
dad's going eat [ __ ] cashed checks
eat [ __ ] cash checks and I remember
saying like yeah you know berm Rogen
said I should do stand-up a focused on
stand-up but II said cash checks right
dad sobbing hi and cream I didn't know
where my dad just started bawling I was
like and I looked at my wife I looked at
my mom I was like [ __ ] dude he sent me
this email today your Papa did today
he's Junior's that grew up close Rogen
is such a good friend cuz Rogen will
tell you the truth that [ __ ] my dad's
going through drive 30 miles my dad's
going through my my grandfather kept a
diary when he stormed the beaches of
Omaha Monday Normandy more Normandy so
I'm posting he's been posting my dad
just and my dad's like getting older so
he's got emotional and he wrote sent me
this [ __ ] email today that was like
he's like as your aging father I want to
offer you some advice based on my life
experiences including my experiences as
your father for which now I'm renowned I
talk [ __ ] about him on my special
certain things in life are important and
to be cherished first and foremost your
family which I feel like you have
mastered and he's off on that cheers to
you and LeeAnn likewise you've been more
successful in your career
you've reached the pinnacle of success
with earnings and we're more imaginable
than I could ever imagine a few years
ago when we sat on that port in
Clearwater your mom my sister your
sisters our mom and your mom myself and
your sisters are so very proud of you
and your achievements but then he said
this is the thing that [ __ ] stuck
with me true wealth is good health I
please have that be impressed upon you
I've had two heart procedures prostate
surgery knee surgery and a nasty blood
infection along with arthritis in both
knees and both hips all I can express to
you and impress upon you is that true
wealth is good health true that dude and
I was like I was like I'm gonna be
drinking in like [ __ ] 20 minutes yeah
when I read that I was like well I'll
work on it tomorrow yeah beautiful great
you have a beautiful thing you know it's
I'm glad he's still alive you know how
old is he 72 not that old not that old
bunch of surgeries oh boo dude he's he a
big boy no he's been he's been he's a
runner his whole life and so he ran
marathons he ran 50 miles every night
get home and run 50 miles and his knees
are just [ __ ] from it two hips and
long running doesn't really doesn't do
your body so weird yeah tell it to Joe
about slow October yeah where I haven't
seen the episode yet would you guys
decide on that with ure tongue we wanted
to do hip hop dance but Joe I'll be so
fun was very adamant about not doing hip
hop Joe Basie decides what you guys are
gonna do no we all vote on it and then
Joe decides what we do yeah I've sold
him so good I had you know how when you
go to pitch a movie you make them feel
like it's their idea and then that's how
you sell it the TV I don't look at that
dude
that's the that's the last over October
yeah is the last yeah last night we
killed one of those models Joe has the
belt on in the new picture yeah Joe's on
the belt again so what are you guys
gonna do he wants to do long distance
run who can run the most at a monk
dumbest with a hey dude like what that's
not a fair
it's not for you it's tougher here for
our like it's bad for your body already
has the body to do it the first of all
I'm the only person in this whole group
who's ever run long distance I really
here I ran the LA Marathon in with no
training in five hours and 33 minutes
that is not by the way my very careful
about the doors I choose I know that
these all inspires out and inspiring Joe
is the most dangerous thing to do in a
competition Joe's running right he runs
on runs a lot
he runs non-stop he's in much better
shape than I am I'm not saying that at
all he's a much better shape you runs
Hills but here's our he wants to do no
social media and I said re I already
doesn't understand this I don't think
he's done enough television to know this
but like has a flip it's not inspiring
to watch someone do nothing now like
it's not fun do something if you said
that motivates you yeah if you said
we're gonna do a sitting still
competition on TV for 32 minutes oh
that's not fun do a dance dude so much
[ __ ] should get on steroids and do a
dance to watch you guys all I'm
definitely doing growth Tim devil are
doing great do a sexy dance why not it
takes so long to get any benefits from
it alright now do a point that the
competitions October and October yeah
not really gonna help you Hawk wins
drawl only wins how we're talking now
you're talking about Dec Hannibal
antiviral and they and then do like the
rock [ __ ] instagrams all its brave by
the way they're right there rocks doing
more than testosterone he's doing drills
about name us do it come on anyone you
want yes check check check check check a
whole [ __ ] cocktail his veins are all
kinds of great best [ __ ] money can buy
but why not wait are you telling me if I
just got cocktail up like that I'd look
like that if I put the work in you have
to lift a lot of weight yeah I think it
inspires you I think they're like I
think they're like really you have to
clean your diet up a little bit like TV
shows I know it's a bummer you get you
get you be fit fat you do you do you do
metabolize carbs much better repair your
body burns higher in the new
testosterone you can't drink alcohol you
get liver cancer right now what are we
talking about by the way after Lance is
some good whiskey Clanton's is great
that's my favorite it's a derivative of
I kind of want to do the running thing
just to see the numbers Joe puts up I
see I the running Ari should beat the
[ __ ] of all you guys he's built for
running
yeah but running and he's a site by the
way Ari is you can't deny Ari when we
did so October last time threw up legit
[ __ ] numbers no our CI dark horse for
you to do a hundred percent Segura is
not a love with running obviously no
when I look at Tom I'm not like there's
a marathoner ya know that no part of you
you run Grogan I've become obsessed with
it and it's gonna be as he's gonna like
built for long distance running if he
can do it don't yes avenues means like
helping him out like I'm running with
him had a desert and [ __ ] do something
you can beat him at dance why is he
afraid of it being a dancer a dancer
that's not that it's out of his comfort
zone but Saul so the only two rogue ins
point it's not really oh it is a workout
is tough dance class is is I took a
dance class my daughter's for an hour
it's gonna be college and pouring sweat
now I but but I thought it's not
mentally tough as like distance he
doesn't want to leave it up to the he
doesn't want to leave it up to a
subjective judging panel to decide who's
the winner he wants a little miracle
number which those guys do what what
else could you do thought the fact in my
brain the for the for creative [ __ ]
the only thing Campbell was long
distance already just all you re every
years like can all social media get on
social media you'd be surprised how help
you are I was like yeah but I mean like
I have tour dates to promote it's like
you're asking me that like if we're
getting on social media where there's no
podcasting like do you can't podcast you
can't promote your podcast no like what
are we talking about but there's a
middle ground like I don't read any
comment I don't know yeah I don't know
and all that you got any comments
I don't read comments I post I put out
content and then you can already at my
friends and I get off or he wants us to
do it the way he does it but by the way
that's about [ __ ] because later is
the surf option still on the table
that's Kelly Slater Oh Kelly Slater just
call me that dude is the surf option
still on the table why don't you [ __ ]
only and I swear to got to get rock are
- he is do you ever see the video of him
falling off his surfboard in the tube
getting back on his surfboard and
finishing the wave he's a legend dude
Kellie's I grew up in Florida do we
idolize know where he grew up though in
Cocoa Beach but then he moved to LA to
serve
he moved yes he did we learned how to
surf in Cocoa Beach I surfed those same
breaks he did monster hole dude all that
she's a shout out to Kelly Slater he'll
he started this clothing brand man I
ordered his clothes what's his clothes
I'll buy him outer limits they won't fit
us why wouldn't I word that they don't
make double x over the XL it came out
like a [ __ ] midriff
hey Kelly you gotta make oh yeah make
out or no and it's dope [ __ ] it was like
oh when you get off the surf and I used
to be a surfer I'm out of known yeah his
Wyatt arks what I find out but I award
his [ __ ] a lot like seven shirts and
none of it fit ah no I like them so much
I didn't send it you're just so big can
I tell you can I tell you who makes all
y'all shirts that I love that I love
there [ __ ] five four No
fight fight fight fight my friend made
our suits a fight Oh our shirts oh yeah
roots of fight sir I gotta tell you I I
love everybody
shirts yeah I just got it do they send
you the jacket no no no I didn't get the
jacket I love me I love roots of fight
but what I have to do is I have to cut
that tag in the neck out cuz I have
tactile a shot me - I have to dive -
literally
painstakingly cut it out dude what do
you mean tactile the Chad's
today and I was like I was like I'm not
gonna wear it I got my sweats I didn't
get those [ __ ] on my house sorry hey
do you uh I need it with the new shirt
you got the new one yeah I just have it
yeah yeah I came out jacket they sent
all you guys a jacket I didn't get a
jacket either I just got that shirt dude
I love I will those sleeveless
sweatshirts they have fav my daughters
have stolen them they love a fave my
daughter's take anything routes a fight
comes to my house they sneak it and grab
it
the Bruce Lee one that's like a like a
it's a sweatshirt but its sleeves
sleeves like cutoff sleeves
gone why don't you make the machine
workout gear for its silver October
like sleeveless hoodies the machine
works a [ __ ] brilliant idea dude
Selleck I don't know where to go I was
bluffing your reader fight he's rich to
fight hit me up hmm
yeah but I can do it I can also help you
with that oh yeah I don't know I'm
reading about that dude that would sell
like crazy dude I love I love the sober
October challenges I'm not I'm not
averse to the running I just I just be a
funner I feel like the only thing that
was the thing that we lose sometimes
does that work comedians it's like he's
like at one point last year I was losing
my mind and Tom's like Burt we're just
comedians like we're not elite athletes
I mean when you guys were doing the yoga
thing and Tom asked me about yoga I can
be honest with you and I'm not hating on
yoga my name I [ __ ] hate yo Tom and I
saw I didn't get much benefit from it I
know some people love it and Rogan
swears by it and if it works for him
great for me as a really super flexible
so you see the split contest we didn't
know that he's trying to get you guys to
do [ __ ] that he's been doing his whole
life he's great yeah I mean okay
so why don't you do a weightlifting and
fighting things or how about instead of
silver October someone try and drink as
much as Bert what's up with that well
there's nothing to happen we talk but
that's the same thing right like yeah
Joe so athletically gifted and you know
he does all these things be equivalent
of you [ __ ] I was a drinking contest
with them Joe his whole life look at
these zombies Abi's yeah I would love
like Joe's accountant Joe's a little bit
like my debt my my dad because of my dad
tried to go to therapy and he just he
was like yeah I don't the [ __ ] you're
talking about I think I'm good like I
would love to hear Joe in therapy
because my dad's a guy he's like well in
my day told my dad you how often he wash
your car my dad goes every morning I
kept washed my car and the guy goes die
we that's obsessive compulsive disorder
my dad goes now and my dad goes stands
up goes the window goes which car is
yours the guy tells him my dad goes your
car looks like a piece of [ __ ] you drive
around the city like that he goes yeah I
don't got a problem
go [ __ ] yourself and walk down the
therapy haste yeah yes my dad's brain
he's like nah I got a nice car I keep it
clean I want to look nice I want people
to that's the way my dad is but like
Joe's like my dad had like it's like
they're very similar brains it works
yeah it works for the
like Joker's no we're running we're
running yeah all three of us have said
we can't get into another competition
that Joe simply excels at and try to
compete with right he's already he's
already ahead of you and all three of us
crumbled were like running no I would
have been like Tom went with it feel
like Tom danced so bad
Tom wanted to do hip hop dance yes we
haven't decided we saw you guys do the
hip hop dance you know you're doing
you're running I've already we're
running why don't you let children why'd
you guys let you run and you guys just
do hip-hop pants
that's not engines running those [ __ ]
because it's fun texting back and forth
for that month and I kind of want to see
like you know it's like I think ours the
darker there was a guy there was a guy
for Tripp flip one time we went in and
we shot at a Greg Greg Jackson's gym in
hop yeah and we had a we had two
travelers that was the purpose of the
show we took two travelers to have a lot
adventure of a lifetime so the one guy
traveler fought Tim Kennedy and so and I
said I said to him listen man you're
never gonna get a chance to knock out a
[ __ ] heavyweight champ like you gotta
take this swing out of take one real
swing at him tug the Tiger's tail just
one time and the kid looked at me a
thrill I go oh yeah you got it he gets
in the ring with a kid Tim Kennedy and
they're play fighting for TV you know
and then I just start going down the
Tiger's tail and he takes a swing at Tim
Kennedy and connects and he sees it in
Tim Kennedy's eyes like oh we're [ __ ]
around huh and all the sudden you watch
this guy go I'm gone I'm gone I'm out of
here like it was but thank you yes one
of the things like we did I did it with
Joe last year is I was making video
because Joe would like to videos like I
just ran two miles sober October I'm
killing it I'm here with Marvel alright
and then I made a joke video no one got
the [ __ ] joke I go alright Joe but
watch your videos I'm up here with my
dog you run two miles I run four [ __ ]
miles I think all right Priscilla where
are you
Rossella Brazil a lot I pretend I lost
my dog right all he heard was you run
two miles I rent a yard that's all
you heard and dude the next day he's on
a podcast with Whitney Nikki Glaser and
he's like he's like I'm gonna break Bert
I wanna break that's why I said I would
just want to break I don't want to break
him it's like psycho what gonna come
whatever haven't met me for me it's like
I don't know if you're gonna if you're
gonna have a competition you gotta have
a competition with a guy who's already
doing it
like I'm a lot of people relate to Bert
and Tom doing it and my Rojo's an
extreme Josie jo make it was fun to it
he gets extreme with it he makes us get
extreme with it we probably go out of
our comfort everyone gets better yeah
and I woke up this morning but hit that
the fix is in he's still gonna win
because that's all he doesn't know he's
been doing this is what's wrong with my
brain you think you and beat him that's
why I like it you're full already I've
already wrapped it up my head I stay on
the bus I stay on the bus all of October
I don't want to LA once I'm going I'm
out I'm out I'm all throughout duration
every city we go to I have them drop me
off 30 miles outside that city on the
bus and I run my way into that city
every [ __ ] 30 miles a long way you're
gonna stress fracture I've got to do it
well I'm listening I'm gonna train I'm
gonna train for a marathon sleeting
that's why that's over so can I just
link the next marathon you're in oh it's
gonna be October first
so Jesus you know do you know how they
do you know sometimes they'll train like
there's an Olympic long-distance coach
yo trains as athletes so just especially
in the beginning as you're getting into
it believe it or not you could do one of
two things one is they'll have you walk
as fast as you can will speed walk seven
minutes no no listen and speed walk back
I don't know fill dirt you'll build your
your endurance write this down huh you
know it's not right like say speed walks
mi ever there's a guy there's a guy
who's an Olympic he's one of the most
winning Olympic long-distance coaches
and then he has a whole thing about this
or they'll take you on a treadmill put
it at your the I going to get inclined
and you'll walk just walk as fast at
four miles an hour for 15 minutes called
the beast
good luck with that but you will you
will build your your cardiovascular
endurance where you'll run without
no better thing having serious dude get
on EPL dude yeah it's bad for his heart
he's gotta be careful now you better
after you get a guy he's model - yeah
dude I'm telling you I cuz you start you
start thinking your head just okay this
is what's wrong with my brain this is
what's immediately wrong with my brain
what if I beat Joe like this let's
hypothetically let's play that visionary
oh you don't competition why don't you
have a speed walk we just told birth to
do that
yeah it looks so [ __ ] weird the two
days like what if you what if what if we
were to beat them and you imagine the
somebody's gonna die cuz if joke cuz yet
you guys can monitor it right you da Joe
is gonna see like a day before but go
I'm a hundred miles away from beating
Burt he's gonna run like a hundred miles
did the night or something like that
yeah Joe will do crazy Joe does I don't
have Joe's brain he doesn't you guys
don't care as much as I go into a math
of it where I go okay if I walked at a
4.5 as 15 minutes I if I walk in a 4
that's that's 15 minute miles now if I
did 10 of those that's 150 minutes I
start doing the math of it Joe just goes
I'll just do it until my dick bleed yeah
weird hold me off of him I'll do it
until like his brain is not my brain
different but there's there's fighters
like the I remember guys like I'm
willing to die they're like you seem in
trouble throw that towel roll that tohe
podcast because I'm one guy I've never
been like that have you ever have you
ever heard about like with yesterday and
this is just scratching the surface I
said so what do you think about when you
run hills he goes that people are
chasing me or raping my family on top of
the mountain and I go there's some do
you think about I just go like oh I want
a cheek tonight on [ __ ] gay men she's
from the girls one more mile yeah I'm
like I'm gonna have a cabbie yeah yeah
I'll run three more so I can eat that
egg yeah I'm using my childhood were you
safe as a child or were you not I was
very safe I there
see I didn't feel very super safe we're
talking about candy [ __ ] to run extra
miles you guys time again [ __ ] dude
rape I told someone I turn on when I
told someone I was molested and I didn't
realize I had been molested yeah yeah
yeah I was like oh that counted like
that's how [ __ ] safe I was this story
I was running a how deep into it I was
running a half marathon with jim
Florentine and like yours how many
concussions do you think you had I said
oh I probably had a few and he goes
really I said I won so bad they had to
wake me up every hour and fill my
testicles
he was like uh-huh and I was like yeah
like that's how bad it was like that
wake me up and feel my testicles and
dick like every hour and he was like
Danny hey man I think you were molested
and I was like what
here's like I think you were molested I
go no no not a god that's like they give
you a physical news number they just
wake you up they just write yeah I was
we were running I laughed so hard I was
like guys I was like wait was i I was
molested and we laughed so and he was
like I never do that ever
see if you can get hard cuz it there's a
parasympathetic dude frontal Miguel
cortex I have no like I didn't hold me
back it didn't bother me and we laughed
hysterically and I was like are you
serious and he was like the look on his
face made me dial up he goes you know
when you get a concussion they don't
have to bill your balls at all yeah but
yeah I grew up very safe I mean I think
that's the problem with me is that like
I I'm everything they hate about white
privilege I go oh yeah like we were I
was saying this to you the other night I
go I'm so shocked people care about
things as much like I don't care about
[ __ ] anything like like I just go
meet our lives matter okay oh yeah oh
yeah I see I
i extrapolate I go well that idea canes
hold then what happens is order breaks
down then you have the government
collapses and you have a song of roving
gangs
so I got to buy guns I go throughout the
whole farm like Bernie and Rogan we'll
go we'll go all the way
birds were raised on safe a little bit
yeah yeah really yeah very you
definitely had an unsafe life yeah okay
yeah yes cat yeah but in a lot of people
go the comics have to be dark and have
to be sad like I know lolly guys who
aren't now very funny
I'm just silly yeah I like giggling so
does Julie I so do you I live to be a
silly goose
yeah I mean I function obviously anybody
know you're super silly you're silly as
[ __ ] yeah the silliest comical I've Leah
Todd glass oh my god no one's funnier
than Todd glass you ready I know what
you're about to do are you about to read
text from Todd glass please this is
great innings if you are lucky enough to
know Todd glass you'll get these type of
texts from Todd glass
I'll read mine first you read you're so
funny you ready yeah hey Burt you know
it would be fun if we just do a whole
show you just have doctors and foods and
presence and it'll be better for people
that if they can't cook wouldn't that be
great we give them great tips maybe
that's July 1st July 2nd because you
didn't get right back to me
I hope the next time you're in New York
there's another 9/11 two seconds later
oh my god I'm sorry that was meant for
my sister he's [ __ ] great great I get
this Julia
the me and Brennan on the same text just
goes my bank account can't get below 1.3
mil lol the bills come in but I it I
just keep making more make it I just
keep period making period more period
Brendon ha ha I go Chris and then Chris
goes yo also Brandon because Brandon
laughs he goes then I just get this from
Chris there's a pause that Chris goes I
can [ __ ] anyone in the ass and I go
that's an obnoxious text what and he
goes
male or female
you simply can't be this respectful he
goes you name anyone and I go
me and he goes I can do it no I'll
[ __ ] come at you like I'll Drive down
there and piece you up i box he goes yes
yes I'll [ __ ] your ass no matter what
and everybody goes hahaha Oh Brandon say
something you know we should do we
should we should do one of the funniest
things ever were you on the email one
page at The Improv accidentally sent
avails out to everyone at CC to everyone
no oh yeah maybe
I love page it was brutal it started off
with like it started off fun this is
gonna get shitty a little bit but it
started off fun with like hey guys I'm
not available to do spots and the fun
was like is everyone on there's so much
dead serious I can't do it and then
someone wrote in the Jeff Ross wrote hey
the Sklar brothers on this and they're
like yeah they're like when you guys do
a spot you have to split the money and
they're like yeah we get paid the same
as Brad Williams we get paid half and
then Brad Williams is hey why did I get
mentioned and then Eliza writes hey guys
this is really annoying can you guys
just take me off this text it was a
shitstorm I think I jumped in and part
of that but it was [ __ ] hilarious we
should start a mass chat thread with all
the comedians we know and we have in our
phone hey guys it's Bert I just included
everyone on this I hope we can all have
fun with you print a book with that okay
just saying what everybody have a nice
day just start with that and here just
get a [ __ ] on no [ __ ] you there's always
that one person like segura going why
did you give up my phone number and Tom
too got a new phone number because I
gave his phone number out on stage one
night do you really wrong yeah no he
doesn't know that totally does now but
he knows it well he knows a little bit
now I don't think this will get to him
you guys can keep a secret right yeah
some people have
one's listening I got drunk and I called
him it I was doing a concept work show
in Tampa and I got drunk and I called
him and it went to voicemail I said all
this to leave over voicemail and he goes
the number is two one and I just gave it
out I didn't realize I was so drunk I
was so drunk you don't hear how drunk I
was that I'd never get a drink on stage
I do drink on stage every now and then
but for the most part I'm stone sober on
stage you really I don't like to drink
on stage especially if I'm doing like my
theater tour body shots world tour
Auckland New Zealand June 15th Sydney we
added a show on the 20th the 22nd in
Melbourne 26th in Brisbane we've added a
show and in Perth on the 29th both those
shows sold out so we added a third
sweeping out the 30th you're going in
Australia yeah yeah I've been there
before I have yeah I love it
how can love it really I should do oh my
god yes he's never done it now I would
want to invest place you ever been yes
talk to you in the world ever I was done
I would even hire let you wear go ahead
I wish I had known that because I would
have just split the money with you and
done the same size venues and I was just
co-headline because I would love that I
would be really afraid of lies
I don't have anyone what a great time
I'm going to miss your friend I'm going
by myself
I would've went with you but I would've
gone I would open for you I woulda
emceed for you what was I saying right
before that what was our about to tell
you the story of and I was like yeah no
and then I started doing tour dates body
shots world tour what the [ __ ] was I say
Oh group group Chad no Segura's phone oh
the drunk driver bit yes so um so I get
done this show if you can find pictures
of it on Facebook like I do the meet and
greet I am so I'm blackout drunk
I'm blackout drunk I ended the show and
they're yelling the Machine and I go no
I'm [ __ ] done please turn off the mic
and walked away right I go I do the meet
and greet I'm blackout drunk I wake up
in a house what city is this Tampa wake
up in a house I've never been in in my
entire [ __ ] I get up and I'm in a bed
I'm Mike oh my god I'm totally naked my
clothes are on the ground that ain't
gonna do the first thing I do is I look
around and I'm like I go
where's my wallet where's my check like
I don't have anything I don't have my
backpack I got nothing it's like four
o'clock in the afternoon please call in
sick to work shows I used to do happen
to 11:00 I do radio I drink it radio I
go in we drink for the show it would be
chaos right they get done it - we'd stay
at the bar and drink I get up in this
house and I walk out I've jeans on now
and I'm like hello no one's there
hello never seen this house in my life
I'm walking around and I'm like it's a
really nice house and I'm like is
anybody here the phone rings you have no
kidney the phone rings I don't answer it
I'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] I grab my phone I
look at my location where I am on my map
I have no I'm in like such a weird part
of Tampa I'm like shot and I grew up in
tap on my shut the [ __ ] up
I look around there's pictures of me up
in the [ __ ] mantle and I'm like how
they have [ __ ] pictures of me like as
a kid you're at superfans house the door
opens my parents are bought a new house
and I [ __ ] forgot about it I was in
there I was like yeah that's yeah Tampa
Connell do this call estate to work
shows anymore dude what's this yeah
that's a while oh that's you put Bert
Kreischer his credit card was stolen
40,000 charged this is good all right
yeah it sounds right did that happen
yeah I think it was a Lakers tickets so
in charge for Teague era yeah yeah
George Lakes with Laker tickets and I
think that's the story I know that money
got stolen
they bought like courtside Laker tickets
so then they call me they tell me hey
this is a while ago they go your credit
card was stolen they've used it to buy
Lakers tickets you didn't buy these
things I said no and they went okay well
we're gonna just so you know we're gonna
be down at the arena and we're gonna
arrest those people the whole those
tickets so I went oh cool I go hey man
what happens to those tickets and
they're like huh I said well like
obviously no one sit in those seats and
they're like yeah well I think we're
gonna just commandeer those seats the
cop said that and I was like oh so you
guys are just gonna
[ __ ] Lakers game right yeah you
[ __ ] give me the tickets yeah
that's like when you're on a plane and
there's like a there empty first-class
seat this drives me nuts and I never
smile but also one like a mom with a
baby wipe I'm like dude yeah no it's
Sydney yeah they won't do it it's so
weird but it is weird when you cuz
sometimes once you offer something now I
guess publicly yeah and everyone goes oh
well I'll just take that from him well
also though also you'd have to like so
what happens is I know what would happen
you got an empty first-class seat and
you go we'll choose you and then the
other guy goes why won't you choose me
what what well but you don't have to
make an announcement lady with a
two-year-old you know it's like my wife
put me on blast on that on a flight
we're sitting in the exit row I'm
sitting in the single seat she's sitting
in the the one with two seats right but
it's an extra legroom and there's a seat
open next to her and I know that we know
that that's available and I'm like you
have that whole row I'll take this we'll
get the whole row to ourselves a guy
walks by I was like six six like a it
looks like a ball player right like a
pro athlete he's white I mean and he
sits he is white and he sits a a seat in
front of my wife and his knees were all
cramped up and I and I just go oh hey
bro you want this seat and he goes huh
I said the seat next to my wife's
available we were gonna have the whole
row but you look uncomfortable well you
have this single seat all sickness my
wife and he goes hey man I really
appreciate that I go of course he sits
down and my wife goes why didn't you
give it to the like the tall girl or the
overweight girl why wouldn't you give
that to and I go yeah and I go what do
you mean she goes cuz they have no value
to you cuz he has value do you only have
man and he's bigger and you look at them
and you go and you [ __ ] up and you're
like hey bro recognize there's women on
this [ __ ] value to you when I was no
good deed goes unpunished I was like how
he looking it was a bit of parade of
[ __ ] [ __ ] just walking past just
I got moose was it that was a mega what
was that the one from but you remember
when booger open the door in in Revenge
of the Nerds how's it the omega moose I
freakin venture the Nerds movie you
you've never seen that movie oh yeah
great movie yeah oh because of that I
[ __ ] up putting a condom on for the
first time yeah do you remember when
they you really got to know this movie I
watch this movie a lot but they walk the
two nerds and the alphas to the Alpha
omegas and they see two sheep there and
they go gentlemen and they go like this
with condoms and they roll out they like
unrolled and they just went bloop and I
went oh so the first time I put on a
condom I go you gotta enroll it like
Revenge of the Nerds or the way my mom
rolls my socks up she was all rolled up
so I unrolled it thinking that's how you
put on a condom I never put light on
them before I'm 17 years old
ice co2 slide it on when I push it over
airs trapped in the side of it and as I
push it just inflates uh-huh and I'm
like trying to squeeze the air out of it
like I make a balloon animal
and so I [ __ ] ruin that condom
there's a first timer toccata mole who
is the girl yeah I know of course I
remember yeah do you hear dating or was
it a one night's dating dating should go
out to Jeff Hartley he's in the living
room or watching Pet Sematary he's with
his girl we had two condoms we got a
member sixteen seventeen years old we
got him into exile on the corner dale
mabry and Erlich so I go over shot the
Exxon so I go over I go hey man I need
that I need that other condom and he's
like you already did it and I go his
long story bless him and he was like all
right so I grabbed it and then words
like reservoir tip pinch the reservoir
tip makes sense to me I know
oh yeah roll it over even putting it off
felt good I was like whew I thought I
always felt weird
oh-ho was the first kind of my better
put on in my life other than the one
where I made the balloon animals so then
I get on top of a real time one done
that's right done one pump one pump
that's meant done oh wow doggy
of course caught me so off hardy man hey
you premature ejaculation now Oh bro I
did all through my 20s blood
when she's like what she looked at me
dead serious looks at a little look on
my face and goes are you gonna put it in
I missed her vagina I [ __ ] between her
butt cheek in the bed and came I didn't
[ __ ] [ __ ] a man and you came and
then I had to [ __ ] her deal with a
compromise opera is like going on a hike
going hey why don't you get those dry
socks and shoes jump in the river real
quick yeah - anything dicks barely well
at that age you're good to go my first
time you never [ __ ] with a condom but
I mean I'm nerv like Jack you're never
on a big condom where were you still not
there for [ __ ] so we doing syphilis
bring it in my even think if I had my
first gay experience I'd be like bro
you're putting on a condom like these
for all you know he's got a [ __ ] movie
that I draw dog me yes Rob do you like
that I'm getting [ __ ] in this game
Bolivia's I was like raw dog Monroe I
want to be infected that was impressive
that was impressive but you're attached
the condom I couldn't feel anything so I
lasted forever and it was so
uncomfortable shoes dry it was a
nightmare
Oh nightmare no not not a good
experience nightmares and there's dad
walked in on us
oh no and he was drunks I didn't realize
what was going on he was like a denier
ball all right you guys tired you can
close the door I'm like tired I'm balls
deep in your daughter here sir yeah what
would you do that's a you guys must be
tired she went quietly I got stiff then
he left she was like oh my god I'm like
anyway anyway
he's not very romantic was not very
porno ish it was awful dry oh that's a
porn that I would like to see two
virgins now I'm not saying like
seventeen year olds I'd like to see two
20 year old virgin stars out first time
I want to see do they have virgin porn
now I don't you know do ya the first
time you have sex is not like let's do
it on camera do you do it though I meant
to tell you when your time at the point
you like I like the taxi cab one British
guy I can't get any picks up the hot
girls yeah he's like you know you don't
have to pay for the fare if you help me
out here I don't wanna do do you still
watch part i watch porn this morning I
don't watch it yeah I watch porn and so
long Oh psychopath I know dude I use the
old memory of a porn I don't even know I
need a good skater jump right to the
money there's one I watched that I got
obsessed with and it was called getting
[ __ ] in the ass on a mountaintop right
okay and it was obscene manner you can
you just google it google it on you on
pornhub getting [ __ ] in the ass on top
see and watch his black and white guys
but guys on guys whatever you want
mountaintop [ __ ] in the ass
mountaintop here's what you're a babe
Rose pissed me off never shows the money
shot at the end it's that girl it's that
girl too far right this one no no the
left to the left oh I want there this
one look first of all there's no high up
dude there first of all my first office
they really like easy hike what a
terrifying hike - no I'm just getting up
you're great workout to hit for him to
[ __ ] me in the ass
what a great weight how bad was the hike
down how is hard is this working woman
working to fix this relationship how
much you stress how much you can paid to
do these lookers mile high heels
she's K yeah well this is fantastic
there you go now this is a dinner date
idea [ __ ] [ __ ] on the mountaintop
look at you
I love doing all they are they in the US
I know Brazil let me see what she looks
like
well those are yeah but they're like no
it's not maybe the guys well she don't
let the fattest all right all right all
right all right
now let's pause here and let's go type
in Brenda from the bar okay this is the
realest port I've ever seen in my life
wait how's that one end this one looks
like I'll be dripping out of you
straight up Brenda from the Brenda from
the bar
I'm actually kind of giant jersey of a
giant erection at the bar me never
princess of the bottle on the bar type
in from the bar maybe it's not Brenda is
Rhonda from the bar I can't you know try
Rhonda for the power
Rhonda's seems likes to be her name this
is a meet to movie cuz Kat there yep
there's Rhonda from the boys you guys
[ __ ] right here oh okay by the way oh
yeah but look at ya ya tell me this
title is that's Wednesday it's early
Wednesday molar deep in his ass don't
want everyone to do the back story of
how this started okay because as it
starts I say to myself okay it's a
Sunday the sunday games were over on the
East Coast
her teams played giant Vilas hit play
it's already seasoned on me so I got a
start a plague engine Oh
my god it's fuzzy you see my computer
the Giants already lost you haven't have
you seen this no I've never seen this I
just do that out she's did I nail it
Burt you nailed this so [ __ ]
brilliantly so I can't tell you yes make
sure you bring that up chin
why what happened she's in a [ __ ]
giant's Jersey sucking this guy's dick
she's wearing a giant and then you go
she clearly works at the bar
it's Sunday the games were over look at
this she's in a [ __ ] giant [ __ ]
Jersey she's in is that a Ron Dayne is
that a barber brains Lee a such a great
attitude and that this looked like you
know that she's like this isn't love
what I do this this what I got dude
that's like first of all guys this is
Midwest freaks calm that guy's so hard
Ringo here's the thing though she's not
really a professional jokes nobody just
got off at like Bennigan's we're making
extra socks yeah doing a good job here
I'm a living in fast-forward
Hey look out flat his asses yeah he has
a terrible body but she's my life that
is Vlad as Wow what she blowing on it
for nothing would she's a she's got a
great attitude I look at her look at her
[ __ ] her Jersey her Suze matches your
real giant bed yet
now she that's somebody straight up how
look at the lighting doesn't even match
up were they lighting the light back
there
Oh some real up she's got three tattoos
ones on her [ __ ] face
yeah oh I just knows the face time she
needs to pay the bills
yeah cuz she's not hot but Brian's
turned on and here's yeah here's how you
know it's homemade he had stains
underwear on Hanes logo is in the
[ __ ] shop
I hate things like God did wash his hand
behind his back I guess for the Campbell
he has no idea what he's doing
fast-forwarded chin let me see what she
starts in his ass don't approve of any
of this there oh here we go
go Giants look at his tattoo Corinthians
Wow in a hairy chest again I think we
got the idea yet a girl lick your ass
bird faster yeah yeah am i right alright
yeah there goes my computer oh don't
this is well you guys have a whiskey on
don't act like you're appalled how dare
you yes alright enough did what the [ __ ]
here's the problem with my wife is that
if I went to yes question if I want to
eat my wife's ass she be like hey you
can't eat my ask them to eat my [ __ ]
I'm gonna get sick my wife my wife a
legit yeah your wife yeah no yeah but I
appreciate that your you guys still have
a yeah I haven't eaten her eyes in a
long time the she that's my wife is like
we did reverse cowgirl I did some one of
my specials we did reverse calendar one
time she's like what is it and I was
like you don't even know what it is like
know what we tell me what to do I'll do
it and I was like will you turn around
sick I face football I was like yeah it
must be pretty born soon as I feel
disconnected like what are you looking
at my [ __ ] oh my god yeah with no
they don't talk like this well now like
yeah now I'm out yeah stop playing
ignorant like my old your ankles know
what reverse cowgirl is first all
yeah I'm just watching a lot of porno
together you guys yeah dude that's way I
used to watch it like ninth grade yes a
new song it's just 52 years old as a
rock but we guys you want her to be an
accomplishment by day the thing is that
thing was more sad than anything though
it's just like a regular gal just got
off Jayant Schloss she's always deep
with some guys that's past when I see a
tattoo like that on the face oh man I'm
like I do too and I think to myself
you're hyper sexual as well and you're
replacing my babysitter right
it's a I like the back stories of porns
do you ever see a woman in a
car like a certain car and she's got
that the dice hanging from the rearview
she's got that she's got the fake nails
nothing been there son if you got
windows huh have you a role you have you
dancing a pole for a living 100% and I
really appreciate that and I know I do I
just pull up roll my window come boat
cash and throw it and go I love them
here's four nursing school
good luck is it good - yeah dude if I
had a nickel for every stripper I fell
in love with yeah so many Duff Davidoff
yeah heat I get it got in a while I went
with Bret Ernst one time right we're
both in Fort Lauderdale and he's like yo
we're gonna go out we're gonna party we
go out and party but it's kind of lame
he goes let's just go to a strip club so
go to the strip club squirrel comes by
she goes you guys want oh my god you
burped the conquerer wells like oh yeah
he's because my kid loves your show like
oh cool
she was like do you mind if I get a
picture I was like I don't mind she's
all right I'll be right back she doesn't
get dressed and I guess backstage tells
all the girls and conquers out all the
girl hell suck they all get dressed and
I take pictures out the front earns just
like dude you look [ __ ] worse to be
with at a strip club they don't got
[ __ ] breasts so I'm in the strip club
since except for us what's the one you
ever good the one in Cleveland by the
old improv it was called god it was
steaming I'm such a prude it was so
intense I had to like shut it down hey
man hey hey be cool last morning be cool
we went to a strip club playing all like
I'm like I don't go to strip clubs
either I don't know we're doing some of
those he's like cool bro hey bro don't
[ __ ] her cool man
we went to a strip club in last morning
in Norway
no no yeah Stockholm know what I was in
one of those one of the last cities we
did in Scandinavia how long ago this is
a couple weeks ago hell yeah
me and mark Normand and so we go to we
go to one and and it's it's called it's
called Waterloo so we go over to the guy
I'm going like hey I'm gonna get is this
place funny because yeah but you guys
need cash we don't take credit cards at
all even for getting in
all right where's bank machine you knew
this though yeah yeah but I thought they
had a bank machine inside every strip
club dies and he goes we don't you gotta
go around the corner suger on the corner
and we see another place called secrets
or whatever so Marcos we should check
out that place we're already so close to
it and it's starting to rain
so we're with our tour manager my
cameraman and mark Normand so we get
money we're over to secrets let me go
hey guys is it fun in there and he goes
yeah but I mean main it may not be the
right place for you guys and we're like
do they do full nude Neos full nude so
do you guys serve alcohol and he goes
yeah I'm like okay what's the prob and
he goes we'll listen guys
our girls are looking for like more of a
commitment and play huh and we're like
he's like you know the kind of girls
they want to take you downstairs and
like be with you you are my brain goes I
don't have to look I get the touch to
all we heard was commitment and we
couldn't stop laughing at like we're
like so what you'd be like good I was
taking on stairs and like hey let's
catch up on Game of Thrones like you
know we should adopt a dog to get there
like we could not laughing and the guys
like you know what I mean come on in
were like no we don't commitment hey
mark Normand you were coming yeah yeah
yeah that's your [ __ ] guy in the road
he took me I would took him with them
he's amazing broken good I mean do you
want to go party so talented man he went
to party and I had no idea you guys were
oh yeah I've just been jerking him off
for the last two weeks
oh he's the best dude next he comes I
have him on the podcast that guy is an
open [ __ ] book he's so funny stories
that I'll [ __ ] blow your mom howdy I
don't know New York guy yeah yeah yeah
I'd known him I'd met him with a through
Amy Schumer a long time ago in Portland
and and I just known him and I knew he
partied and I was like yo let's do
Europe together and I could just you
know I go pretty hard on the road he was
like yeah I got you second day and he
was like I'm [ __ ] - yeah he was like
I broke him quick did he sell [ __ ]
funny he's all Arius man because I I
discovered him I knew of them but I
discovered because I was doing as time
was on Monday but I was doing pressing
Cleveland and he has this epic press
dude you've seen that yeah
dude have you seen my postage that is
the funniest the best ever after here
I'll show you that say so [ __ ] funny
man being around him makes you funnier
right so like cuz he's a joke guy so
he's silly
he likes to giggle no professional of
them again so I came up with this that
was gonna post this on Instagram but it
made mark and I laugh and my wife didn't
get the joke she what's done it says Amy
Schumer presents mark Normand she did a
special yeah it was until he's weird
when comics do that right yeah a little
weird what what she's did he used to
open for her son he did this is what I
was gonna tweet this I was gonna tweet
this tell me it made mark and I laugh it
was gonna mute Marlee Matlin she can't
speak anyway she can't I don't know
she's a deaf actress
Oh Molly Matlin who was in the children
of a lesser God I was gonna mute her oh
my god it's [ __ ] up it's free I was
gonna tweet it out yeah and Mark and I
were dying [ __ ] laughing she's very
political and I was like um you see
headline shows himself yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's on tour yeah he's a beat I was
trying to get him to go to Australia
with me he's like I can't do it man at U
is like oh man like he was like just
going solo go solo working what's gonna
open free some mugs yeah local comics
and then I'd have to go with somebody
it's a it could becomes extremely
expensive though it's so expensive she's
got to fly them out you got to put them
up and you got to pay them well I
brought I didn't bring an open eye cold
open all my shows those theatres no you
just walked up there yourself and
started it and it's in this how it
starts its crash in would announce ago
all right it's not not entertainer so
Jim would get on
oh I don't think that's how he talks
listen Bert that would have been better
because what he did was go ladies and
gentlemen the moment you've been waiting
for you know I'm from fighting the kid
and Showtime Oh God put your hands
together he's my boss Brendan Schaub
great that well know that oh yeah man
that's no joke
I called open for like the first year
really yeah didn't bring anyone yeah I
went all odds against me I figured is
like the worst case in it I reached out
to a lot of people Chris to Stefano I
reached out to I was like dude I love
him too whoo Chris this definitely no
media was supposed to meet up in New
York I feel like me and him are lost
dude brothers he is
oh yeah Connie says a podcast I hang out
with him with that Duff good friends
Duff he's great great guy he always was
connect in New York we're going trading
yams you've called me babe and it was a
little weird so I think to meet up with
God cause let me tell you something Kyle
he's the buzzy cousin Scott Scott right
he's so funny
had him on something's burnin I went out
and did a bunch of episodes something's
burnin in New York he he had me dying
[ __ ] cuz you don't do the [ __ ] is that
the [ __ ] thing oh great I hang along
with him eight times with Doug he's
funny and I loved him run away I go who
is this guy he's he's a great guy him
and Mark I want to get a house there's a
lot of guys that I wish would I wish me
New York New York [ __ ] comics had
just the best so he came on my podcast
and it was so out of the [ __ ] gate it
was like I got warts who gives a [ __ ] i
text you once I saw I was a hazy good do
cuz I love comedy oh he is so goddamn
funny yeah he's all those guys there's a
lot of guys
Yanis Yanis poppy
papas Andrew Schultz you know on your
show he's a piece and he's company I
love the way he's running this business
I think it's the same I think he's got
the same mentality as LA comics ours
like yo but in New York at which it's
harder in New York because everything's
more expensive you wanna shoots on the
evidence more expense but also in New
York its
to me I feel like it's not as a
welcoming community it's more doggy-dog
well here yeah like there are some
[ __ ] in the gamer great comics but
in general we kind of help each other
out I feel like all got on each other
shows by circle-jerk I said I said in
ooh yeah I'm guest Christian dude call
him right now
Calma Calma pious [ __ ] gap dude
when's bark coming out here the biggest
crush on him bring back up that point
that guy balls deep in the other guy
let's just get a joke wait why wait what
happened huh yeah he's seen cat's face
have you met Chris no never met him I
wish let's meet up in New York was
nothing for us but he kept calling me
babe through tax how's it go right well
yeah he suppose I don't know here we go
here we are let's call him dude he is so
[ __ ] funny
and he's just real as [ __ ] like that's
my love and his kids yeah he's got a
daughter and yeah sushi all right here
we go
he was a real question does he answer
when it come from me who's is he son's
got a [ __ ] boy spell he's gonna
answer if he's around he might be
working what time is it there
no it's 4 o'clock there dude
or it's 5 o'clock it's right on a train
it's on the subway that's he's on a
subway bro you drink yeah
they don't get service TV it picks up
the phone use that what the [ __ ] you
want you're on the bathroom I gotta pee
- let's take a break
crystal yo hey I'm sitting here a
fighter and the kid you next time you
come la you have to do this Alma Brendan
and Brian right now you're on the air
right you're on there you're on the area
you're on the air what's what's up bro
we're talking about how funny you are
hey Chris why why you yeah I heard you
were texting with Brennan you were
referring to him as babe yeah
because my father I'm pushing it down so
I got big triceps but I just is there a
very good answer
now let me ask you this what you busy
dice yeah come out now you know you're a
thick you're a thick kind of alpha type
a strong kid now when you're you're gay
obviously attractive do you wanna [ __ ]
Brennan or get [ __ ] by any chemical
concoction the kid expects but I these
matters he's gonna be Joe you can cover
my ass he's in the [ __ ] yeah there's
the aisle next to don't get the claritin
me Chris come on if I take it first of
all Congrats on your hair Congrats on
your big blue eyes and your strong jaw
said that to you in person
and you got two and you got some
shoulders on you so at the end of the
day it hurts me that you could hold me
down but you know I agree you know just
whatever you guys want just let me know
cuz I probably
point of my life as my dad does have
late stench diabetes you know he's kind
of just on the cusp of dying so I can't
just show up at the park and get up to
jerk off a few times we're looking for
are you young man I have to go get her
right there love you man all right I'll
talk to you later buddy is so [ __ ]
funny dude my god you know Grigio to
claritin-d he kills me dude there's so
many of those guys in New York that are
[ __ ] hilarious right now Tim Dylan's
moving out here he's [ __ ] is he
moving out here he's moving out here
yeah we did that we did episodes of
something's burning in New York we did
ten of them and do two every [ __ ]
episode I was dying [ __ ] laughing
that's so weird mark Normand opens up
for him because just [ __ ] talking
about so great yeah he's he's amazing
he's a great comic he makes you it makes
it fun to be a comic I can't get like
like I don't do it obviously I love burr
but like bird's brain is so like dialed
in that we hang out and you come out a
little heavy sometimes really yeah yeah
but uh but like Morgan Norman's just
always silly what about this for a joke
like I came up with a joke I haven't
really figured it out yet but I go I
took showers and I said in our own in
our rooms and we got down on the same
and was the curtain like touching you
and he goes yeah happened to me too I
said the whole time I felt like a ghost
wasn't molesting me and Marcos ah that's
a bit you should work on that and you're
like oh yeah you forget you're a comic
killer yeah
god dammit I gotta work on that like and
so he was great Torres and really
talented now you're going to do a
podcast with Steve Byrne right now Laura
do Steve Burns got a movie called
I'm always amazing did you sign the
trailer for this I saw the movie amazing
child a movie dude
no idea that guy wait you know amazing
no play the trailer dude is where can
they get this movie uh it's on all
things comedy I think right now okay
leave burn all things comedy burns thing
called the amazing is to do oh it's
about it the amazing Jonathan yeah yeah
Jonathan dude yeah there's a tweeted
this is amazing man he was amazing
Jonathan was [ __ ] he was hilarious I
used to do my with my first TV show and
he would murder murder razors movie I
thought I was the trail is he still
alive so he can I was like yeah he can
use his legs
well what happened huh is it a trick he
had drugs and he had congenital heart
failure and then he got stem cell and it
fixed his heart but I guess yeah he has
trouble now I don't know I
yeah it's he partied hard yeah hard at
the party lost the use of his legs what
but I heard good things already the
harder than sessom but he's your
marathons ah yeah well show up to the
amazing Jonathan I know yeah yet going
dude know that I could do this podcast
forever every time I love this that's
not have so much [ __ ] fun I said oh
my go
as we're gonna the bathroom I got a
beast he's the best oh I want that to be
my ringtone especially on that that
that's the whiskey Brian was too good
for it I had a judge just for the your
nose that we like I thought this very
strange Pappy Van Winkle you know
so really Steve over at scopa wants to
give us do it real tasting with us so
mr. bottle bro no no he wants to it
together $3,000 that's not another place
oh dude you can buy know what I bet you
I could squeeze you into the tasting
you're you're a whiskey guy yeah I'm uh
I'm a booze guy - no sin that not
private speakeasy with brass at scopa
what wait why we're gonna do two cocoa
puffs
switchblade do you want to do that
because I can set it up a hundred
percent okay yeah I leave for Bali up
front that they've got really rare
whiskey's really where like there's a
back room there's a there's a speakeasy
in scope it's a secret you know it's
never poppin right so he leaves fall
here front of Bali on Friday and then
I'm an Australian July you come back
when July first
Briony County well yeah I do it the
heartbeat happy I'd be fun van winkle I
never trying we could taste it and then
make sure it's not poison a backhand but
you and I and I'm gonna talk to you
about it Pappy Van Winkle's yeah
tour dates I'm in Auckland New Zealand
June 15th Sydney on the 20th out of the
second show
Melbourne on the 22nd on the 26th in
Brisbane we got it a second show a month
I'm at the met in Philly I'm also a show
in - bolita throws world I'm gonna met
in Philly so follow
July 27th come see me this weekend
Indiana helium Indiana please do please
buy those Indy I bet he's not any longer
we saw that we salute at 17 tickets he's
both 17 tickets it's a high state no I'm
just kidding yeah I was very proud of it
but no but so have you ever have you
ever called have you ever called a you
wouldn't do a fun game before we leave
no second you've ever done this let's go
gay let's call the Indianapolis club and
see what they say about you when we ask
Indianapolis helium yeah okay this is a
Las Vegas hop beat over there is fun
okay it comes to me in Tempe smaller
rough either this weekend June 20th
hello good how you doing I'm doing a
podcast you're on the podcast yeah
Bryan Callen and Bernie sob stories
about you today about the conversation
we had at the beach house when uh when
you I told you about each hit cash
checks and you got emotional that's my
dad I talked about the letter you sent
me today about true helpers in the world
all right well we're wrapping up the
podcast I'm heading home I'll give you a
call on that well I call clubs about
myself all the time to see how they sell
me I really not want to not the okay
call the club and go hey who do you have
this weekend and they go I don't [ __ ]
know oh and you're like I will keep you
maybe look it up and they're like Brent
crystals and you're like is he funny and
you're like I don't know man and then
you go who's next week there goes oh boy
he is [ __ ] amazing damn it I did it
with Jo koy one time have you got him
not in a necklace no indeed no come see
me at Tempe June 20 at 2122 Tempe improv
I'm excited um Burbank this Saturday
Rappaport Fahim a sauna with me that's
one giant show that's Saturday night I'm
in Vegas with Brian there are 50 tickets
left at the Orleans in Calgary Yuk Yuk's
June 20 through the 22nd not that I'm
rheya the new Brea brea June 27th to
29th get your tickets tik calm Bert we
love you man
dude I love you guys thank you so much
this is the fighter the kid in the
machine we're out